is Apple's magic keyboard folio really
worth 250 dollars and how does it
compare to the original magic keyboard
which I've used since it came out and
I've loved everything about it other
than the 300 price which you can now buy
for a hundred and sixty seven dollars
and our iPad Pro and air users missing
out with this new keyboard well I've
been using it for the last four or five
days and I have a lot of thoughts about
it both positive and some negative so
some very weird quirks so we're gonna
compare all of the differences between
these two and I'll give you guys my
honest opinion about this new keyboard
or if you should buy another alternative
the apple does not want to advertise but
Kim's in much cheaper and with more
features now getting right into it the
reason why I even wanted to put a
comparison in this video is because you
can buy this magic keyboard for super
cheap now refurbished and an iPad Air 4
for 418 dollars making the full iPad Air
pack package with a keyboard come in at
585 bucks total compared to 700 for this
new tension and we did a full comparison
between these iPads and the iPad Air
even in 4chan actually beats out the
ip10 in many ways so if you have not yet
bought an iPad 10 you should definitely
pay attention I want to start out with
the weight and the thickness that got 10
by itself actually weighs more than the
iPad Air but when you factor in the two
keyboards the magic keyboard original
one is quite a bit heavier than this new
magic keyboard folio but surprisingly
the iPad 10 setup is thicker because of
the design of the keyboard but the
footprint is slightly smaller because of
this hinge portion now the hinge on the
folio which is an upside also brings
with it a downside which I'll talk about
in just a bit but as you see it's not a
complete hinge it's very floppy because
of this design on the back the reason
it's thicker is because we have our
kickstand that is adjustable and it
allows you to be able to have it stand
almost vertical not exactly and then be
able to be brought down in terms of the
angle the original magic keyboard has a
laptop like design which also means that
you can actually set the angle like this
if you put it up high but once you get
it up this high you can twist the actual
iPad higher and if we look at the total
angle it pretty much matches up with
that said one thing I really like about
the magic keyboard is that your iPad is
floating and that brings it closer to
your face making the screen look bigger
and it's more comfortable without having
to look down as much as with the new one
I also really like how compact it is
because the overall surface area that
you need to be sitting on a desk and for
example a tray table on an airplane is
very small and that means it's all very
compact compared to the folio which you
have the keyboard that sticks out a lot
more if we line up the screens you guys
see that right here and then the
kickstand is also way far back because
of that you need 50 more area to get the
same angle 14 inches compared to nine
and a half and for some people that
might not matter but like I said if
you're on an airplane with those tiny
tray tables that is so nice to have this
compact package and if you're out
somewhere say a restaurant you have this
set up or a coffee place it is nice to
be this compact now with that said the
key standout feature that a lot of
people like is the fact that you can
detach that keyboard and now bam if you
don't need that keyboard you're not
typing using the trackpad well you have
this super compact little setup where
you have great magnetic strength you
have protection there on the back and
you could still watch or do whatever on
your iPad and it is nice and small with
a magic keyboard that keyboard is always
there even if you don't want on it if
you're letting your young kids use it
that's not a great thing because they're
always touching and messing stuff up now
with that if you want to use your iPad
in landscape well that is kind of
annoying having that keyboard be there
whereas with the iPad 10 bam you flip it
there you don't have the same kind of
angles unfortunately but at least it can
stand up almost vertically and you can
set it up next to your monitor things
like that now as far as the keyboard
both of these feel really nice but I
would say that the magic keyboard
actually feels better now that I've
gotten to use both of them and using
them side by side I don't know if it's
just the feedback I feel or what but I
can tell a difference now looking
slightly below both have excellent track
pads that have a really really great
clicking feel even though they're not
magnetic like we have on the MacBooks
but I would actually say that the one on
the folio actually feels slightly better
and with that you guys can see the
difference in size days now the width is
almost the same but when we stack him up
the magic folio one has much more room
because of the design and being able to
use uh the larger area here instead of
having a section be behind or below the
iPad and in daily use it definitely is
nice to have that extra space now
probably the killer feature with the
folio that people that have an iPad Air
or Pro with this one want to have is
that function row using it it is so nice
to have being able to adjust your
brightness quickly your volume hitting
that mute switch if you need to mute it
be able to control your media whereas
with the magic keyboard I'm doing stuff
then I have to go in and adjust my
brightness like this or my volume being
able to skip a track if you're playing
music in the background which I like to
do it is so nice to have that and I
really wish this one had that but
flipping to the other functions the
amount magic keyboard has that USB
type-c port so you can plug it in to
charge and that cable runs flat on your
desk and then you still have access to
the USB type-c port if you want to
connect any sort of external media any
accessories that is really nice to have
that flexibility which with this one
they did not add that functionality so
you have that cable hanging off the side
of charge and if you need a charge you
can't plug anything else unless you
wanted to use other external adapters
that are going to click on the side
there now the last thing for the
comparison that is a huge bummer that I
was not expecting if you're spending 250
bucks is the fact that the keyboard does
not have any backlighting built in I
think it's unexcusable for this kind of
a price tag if you're buying it whereas
the magic keyboard all those keys are
backlit and it is so nice to have us if
it's a little bit darker if your kids
would want to use it and they're not
great at touch typing it is very
convenient I have no idea how or why
Apple left that out I mean if it was 150
bucks 200 bucks still sucks uh
especially with the alternative I'm
going to share but I mean with this
price tag it is just crazy that they
didn't add it and now let's close this
thing down and I want to share my
experience with this folio now when I
started using it I really liked it even
though a lot of times I was using it
with the keyboard I love the fact that
this section is larger my hands are
resting right here compared to off the
keyboard before and the whole thing
works great and using the trackpad it is
definitely nicer especially if you're
scrolling through websites having that
extra vertical space has been awesome
compared to you know me being used to
using the magic keyboard and being able
to pop this off when I don't need that
and just set this up for my kids to
watch some videos has also been really
nice because my youngest son Elon he
will just try to touch the track pad
he'll try to type you know the video
goes away then he has to call me so just
being able to do this and being able to
set it up has been awesome I was also
very surprised by the strength of this
attachment it is crazy all right I went
a little too far there shaking it but it
is very solid and even though this is
also magnetic and Clicks in like that it
is insane how strongly this attaches
you're not going to be worried about it
at all now one thing that I also did not
expect it kind of disappointed me is how
this connects with this iPad it is
extremely solid it's on a hinge this is
not going anywhere and with the new
folio well if you look at this it is
just sliding all over the place when I
put into my bag if I'm holding it I
would think that Apple would add some
additional magnets here so it actually
stay in one place I can imagine you know
some dust or and or anything getting on
here and then it being able to rub back
and forth in your bag wherever you put
it that would cause a lot of scratches
on that screen so it is very weird how
we don't have anything holding this
together and another thing I discovered
is that with this hinge which is nice
and stiff sometimes I wish it went a
little bit lower I know with this one it
has the same angle but it makes sense
because you have a multi-hinge here it's
more limited but why not allow it to go
lower here the Logitech keyboards that
we've tested and reviewed go way lower
than this and that is nice to have to be
able to adjust if you're on a standing
desk or doing something else or if
you're going to be drawing with the
apple pencil this angle is not the best
if we can have it be slightly lower like
this that's a lot more comfortable now
unfortunately I still haven't been able
to test it out because my adapter has
still not arrived so I can't even pair
it but I think this is a major oversight
with a keyboard that I use as is this
kind of design even Microsoft Studio
desktop goes way low for a great angle
if you're drawing or doing anything else
now my last complaint about this folio
is that it only comes in white instead
of having the option to have white or
black now white looks super cool super
clean but it is very hard to keep clean
here is my keyboard for the 12.9 inch it
is white and as you guys could see I
have a bunch of dirt lines stuff like
that that just built up and I don't just
take this outside in the park anywhere
where it's too dirty and believe it or
not I actually watch this thing first
with water and a microfiber cloth then
with alcohol and this is what's left it
was way dirtier than this and this stuff
right here does not want to come off so
if you're going to be using this thing
well that definitely is a downside I
wish they offered it in Black so with
all of that said do I think this is
worth 250 bucks and should you spend
your money on it well overall I love
some of the design features and
capabilities but I think that price
point is way too high now it is Sleek
it's fairly slim it's not that heavy but
that's just a lot of money and if you're
looking for an alternative Logitech just
launched their new keyboard which they
had for previous ones but they adjusted
it for the iPad 10 but unfortunately
Apple did not put it on their website
like they have the other ones you have
to get that directly from their website
and also link it down below maybe to
Amazon as well and that's probably
because they don't want to take away
sales from this keyboard because the
other one does have a lower angle it
does have backlighting it also uses that
SMART connector you can detach the
keyboard as well so it costs less money
it has more features it's not a cheap
Bluetooth only keyboard the only thing
is there your iPad pops into it which
does mean that you get extra protection
here all along the side AIDS so it's
also a little bit thicker but at that
price point I think that's definitely a
winner now overall if you have not
bought an iPad 10 just yet well I say
overall I would take the original
keyboard instead of this design yes it
has some limitations you can't detach
that keyboard but have the ability to
charge and having that backlighting and
being able to pick up a package for
under 600 bucks all together with an
iPad that is better instead of spending
700 I mean I think that is the smart
thing to do so that is my opinion you
guys let me know yours check out the
comparison between the iPad Air 5 and 4
compared to the iPad 10 right over there
click that Circle above to subscribe
This One Max and I'll see you in the
next one
[Music]
foreign